[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
les outre-mer au coeur de la stratégie
maritime nationale
alors que la france deuxième espace
maritime mondial s'est dotée en 2017
d'une stratégie censée donner un cadre
et un cap à son ambition maritime notre
pays peine à valoriser son immense
potentiel situé à 97% danse et outre mer
annick petrus philippe folliot et marie
laure phinéra horth dresse un bilan
critique de la stratégie maritime menée
dans un rapport rendu public le 24
février 2022 quelques jours seulement
après le premier sommet mondial de
l'océan à brest
pour la délégation sénatoriale aux outre
mer la priorité est aujourd'hui
d'inverser notre regard en replaçant les
outre-mer au coeur de la stratégie
maritime nationale en crédibilisant
notre souveraineté mise à mal sur ces
zones économiques exclusives z 2e et en
accompagnant la transition économique
ultra marines
une révolution culturelle doit en effet
être engagée autour de l'océan
les français n'ont pas assez pris
conscience de la nature archipélagique
de leur pays
par exemple les infrastructures de
plusieurs ports ultramarins sont
inadaptés face à l'explosion du trafic
par porte conteneurs qui devrait tripler
d'ici 2035
face aux menaces croissantes en mer
notamment la pêche illégale les
narcotrafics le réarmement navale le
développement de la cyberguerre à
proximité des câbles sous marins par
lesquels transitent 95% des données
mondiales la souveraineté maritime
française doit être consolidée pour
crédibiliser les ambitions françaises
savez vous que le nombre de
patrouilleurs destinée à la surveillance
de la z française est équivalent à deux
voitures de police pour surveiller le
territoire hexagonal
face à ce sous dimensionnement des
forces de souveraineté les autres maires
doivent être la priorité de la future
loi de programmation militaire estime la
délégation aux outre-mer
pour parvenir à crédibiliser notre
souveraineté maritime la délégation
préconise de faire de la stratégie
maritime un moteur de l'insertion des
outre-mer dans l'économie mondiale
par exemple l'inde au pacifique
concentrent 60% de la population
mondiale et 60 % du pib mondial à
l'horizon 2030
avec ses six territoires du pacifique et
de l'océan indien la france est le seul
état de l'union européenne présents
après la crise des sous marins
australiens il convient de renforcer et
de diversifier nos partenariats
stratégiques dans cette zone et une
implication plus marquée des
collectivités ultramarines permettrait
de ne pas limiter la stratégie indo
pacifique à sa seule dimension militaire
pour découvrir les 40 propositions dans
la perspective de la prochaine stratégie
maritime 2023 à 2029 qui nécessitera une
large association des élus de chaque
territoire ultramarin à son processus
d'élaboration
consultez la synthèse du rapport
[Musique]